le suspense continue le décollage de la
navette spatial space x a été reporté
hier en raison des conditions
climatiques
orages vents et risque de foudre la
prochaine tentative aura lieu samedi à
19 heures 22 heures françaises space x
marque le début d'une nouvelle ère dans
laquelle les états unis confie pour la
première fois au secteur privé le
transport de ses astronautes pour en
parler de ce premier vol habité à bord
d'une fusée space x et nous sommes en
direct avec patrick baudry spationautes
deuxième français est reparti dans
l'espace merci beaucoup d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt français patrick baudry
qui on le rappelle a effectué une
mission de 16 jours
en 85 à bord de la navette discovery
michel polacco à ses côtés journalistes
spécialistes aéronautiques merci à vous
aussi à michel polacco d'être en direct
alors déception au hier évidemment on
était tous suspendus à nos écrans vexé
ces deux astronautes habillé en héros
américains et finalement pas ça a été
annulé alors pour le grand public qui ne
sait pas tout patrick braud de baudry on
rappelle que ces fenêtres de tir sont
sont très réduites et sont très
sensibles bien évidemment à la météo
oui bien sûr nous donnait 30 ans qui est
serrée puisque c'est une question de
pognon pour arrestation et ensuite la
maison c'est toujours un problème pour
trouver lancement aux etats-unis en
floride
elle mettait parfois très délicate avec
des orages et c'est ça comme ça a été le
cas encore
et donc si jamais gagné le moindre j'ai
eu plus de dix autres annulations aux
tirs donc selon elle des souvenirs c'est
pas très bien le monde reprend de tir
sexuellement alors mais alors justement
patrick baudry passe quand je mourrai
dedans vie de leur poser la question
hier donc j'en profite avec vous j'ai
cette chance ce soir qu'est ce qu'on
ressent pas ce qu'on imagine une
pression terrible quand on est dans
cette navette rond et envoie la dette
propulsé puis à 3 minutes on nous annule
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on ressent à
ce qu'on ait préparé à ça je m'échine
tôt oui quand même un peu oui bien sûr
une grande frustration puisque on espère
toujours partir le compte à rebours
s'égrène pour on ne sait pas et groen et
ils savaient qu'ils de fortes chances de
ne pas partir et d'un volet la météo
mais mur - on se prépare en quarantaine
pendant une semaine deux semaines et
donc on attend la démence en fait et
lorsque ça ne part pas et bien c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas évident à
vivre un bon leader parce que le choix
de poser les problèmes qui n'ont d'être
mais néanmoins voilà moi ça m amuse et
des mois qu'on demande indigène a cessé
sa modernité dans beaucoup changé moi je
suis tout surtout un admirateur de nos
masques et 2 statiques c'est de la
fabrique à nîmes sous le fait au nom des
arrestations ces c'est dérisoire c'est à
dire l'importance ce que j'attends c'est
qu'on envoie des touristes un kit haider
leur voyage en orbite basse puisque leur
big ben a sonné professionnel je suis
simplement ridicule en devenir mais
celle pour les compos là qu on a
beaucoup parlé d'une nouvelle ère socke
west east oric d'abord je sais du bruit
patrick baudry qui évidemment lui a eu
l'honneur et le bonheur de voler dans
l'espace
le risque c'est une nouvelle ère quelque
part oui d'abord le retour des
américains dans l'espace après qu'ils
aient fait quand même la conquête de la
lune c'est obligatoirement un événement
deuxièmement ça fait dix ans que les
russes ont ce monopole
les chinois aussi avait la possibilité
de le faire mais il n'en menaient pas
d'étranger et donc ça veut dire que les
russes vont peut-être avoir un problème
de finance et de rentabilisation de la
refuser leur vaisseau soyouz
troisièmement on attaque une nouvelle
phase de la conquête spatiale puisque là
ce sont des entreprises privées puisque
l'as sp6 d'elon musk qui au passage je
vous rappelle à amener ses astronautes
hier soir au pâtir l 39 a quitté le pas
de tir des fusées apollo avec une
voiture tesla les tesla est donc c'est
plus ce sont des entreprises privées
speccy que c'est boeing qui vont se
retrouver en concurrence d'ailleurs avec
les russes et avec les chinois
et on sait que le prochain objectif
c'est pas comme le disait patrick baudry
tourner autour de la terre dans la
station orbitale internationale
le prochain objectif c'est d'aller sur
l'ale de retourner sur la lune et
ensuite de partir à la conquête du monde
sidéral de mars des astéroïdes et
d'autres places de l'espace qui attise
notre curiosité et qui sont évidemment
génétiquement chez l'homme des lieux qui
nous intrigue et que l'on a envie de
découvrir ça vous semble justement
réalise patrick baudry qu'on en arrive
là parce que évidemment c'est l'objectif
que poursuit elon musk que poursuit
aussi richard branson
même s'il a un petit peu freiné ses
ardeurs ces derniers temps on rappelle
quand même que c'est un effort de 2 18
ans il ya quand même eu des fusées qui
se sont au crash sp6 et enfin on arrive
à quelque chose donc le tourisme spatial
c'est pour demain selon vous bien sûr il
dit mais je suis très heureux d'entendre
les français michel dire que l'objectif
c'est mars et au dollar alors que
pendant trente ans nous a complètement
occulté ces genres de de target
alors le doigt est le neveu ce qui est
qui et pour moi et j'ai mis et qui a une
réussite
absolument extraordinaire le falcon
lines est un lanceur vraiment magique et
je suis non pas certain que jamais
l'être mais j'espère que et le must pour
atteindre son objectif qui est mars
envoyer quelqu'un de sûr mars est donc
tout ça où l'on voit le voir dans les
années qui viennent on va retourner sur
la lune dans les touristes faire le tour
de la lune
tout pousse tout ça on verra et il faut
bien le dire à 7,7 ces stations cette
station se passe elle est un peu
ridicule comme styliste fait pas mal de
temps et donc c'est le début d'une
nouvelle ère avec de la technologie
vraiment plus qu'une plus performante
que ce mutisme et entonner et le fait
que la nasa qui est quand même une
administration un peu un peu mollassonne
je dirais d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'a dit
ruff à l'administrateur de la nasa
il n'y a ni remonter les bretelles lundi
le produit encore jeune n'est pas de
dire que continuer à aller là 400 km de
la terre ça c'était bien j'ai beaucoup
apprécié et donc les administrations
devienne un petit peu incompétente n'ont
pas assez compétente et donc c'est le
privé qui a peu qui prend la relève avec
des lampes aux menaces que manson et c
est donc c'est vraiment le but clean ou
l air chaud aller plus vite moins cher
plus loin les plus sûres et justement on
l'appelle souvent cette fusée low cost
qui manifestement on le comprend dans
vos propos ont fait mieux voilà en
termes de rapport qualité prix que que
la nasa vous parliez également d'apollo
quelle différence entre le coucou dragan
et la capsule apollo on imagine que tout
a changé dans la cabine tout a été
évidemment moderniser un point qu'on
n'imagine pas michel polacco évidemment
il s'est pas dit il s'est écoulé 50 ans
vous imaginez bien quand on a fait du
chemin
toutefois le principe la capsule puisque
vous parliez de navettes tout à l'heure
donc la navette elle est abandonnée
navettes spatiales auront servi à des
capsules qui sont au bout de fusée en
eau et qui ensuite reviennent sur terre
accroché sur des parachutes sous des
parachutes et se pose sur la terre ferme
ou dans l'eau et donc ce sont des
calculs qui sont sous cet angle là tout
à fait classique et traditionnelle avec
un bouclier thermique pour pouvoir
revenir dans l'atmosphère avec un espace
souvent un peu réduit bien que là le
crew dragon est fait pour accueillir
jusqu'à sept personnes a donc un
portable que ne l'était apollo qui ne
pouvait en accueillir que 3 et c'était
quand même très serré comme d'ailleurs
le soyouz de jean chrétien et compère de
patrick baudry qui quand vous le voyez
quand vous imaginez ce qu'étaient ces
pauvres trois cosmonautes serrés comme
des saucisses et quelquefois pour 48
heures
et ça a été plus long même pour d'autres
d'ailleurs enfin bon là c'est plus
confortable
c'est plus large ils sont mieux
installés ils sont mieux climatisé
ils ont évidemment des instruments de
pilotage de navigation qui sont plus
modernes
enfin ça c'est relativement simple et
rustique quand même et ça marche très
bien
il n'y a pas des choses très complexe à
faire donc non c'est pas ou si on est en
train de mettre en othe fusée qui sont
comme la fusée 7,45 d'apollo des
capsules qui sont comme les capsule
apollo du programme apollo
quelque part 50 ans après on peut pas
dire que tu es une révolution il n'y a
pas eu de révolution pas très gros des
beaudry pardon on disait quand même oui
allez via les haies et l'évolution quand
même très très grand c'est un peu comme
si l'on comparé à la 4 l à fait cela non
mais là est ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que en ce qui concerne
l'espace habité on voit des hommes dans
l'espace
on est resté avec la 4 l affaire
pratiquement souligne michel pendant ce
temps dans trompent pas et c'est
peut-être drink que j'aime bien beaucoup
et c'est un mythe rapide amis très
proches savaient le deuxième marché sur
la lune qui est qui à dire pendant
l'interview au mois de mai dernier qui a
dit ça fait 30 ans qu'on craint c'est
honteux
il a dit à trump et c'est là que trompe
pour remonter les bretelles de
l'administrateur de la nasa
je crois qu'il faut c'est la même chose
avec les agences française et européenne
qui naissent les ars et c'est vraiment
la belle au bois dormant
alors ces deux astronautes ont leurs
appels américains vont rejoindre quand
même deux russes et un autre américain
on parle toujours de degas guerre vous
me disiez les russes qui domine et voilà
là ce sont les américains qui vont
peut-on imaginer même si ce sont des
privés américains qui mènent ces projets
voilà qu'on se rassemble dans un projet
avec les russes les chinois les
américains où ça va vraiment devenir une
guerre une course à l'espace michel
polacco court succès sur guerre je ne
crois pas d'abord depuis apollo soyouz
et la rencontre dans l'espace des russes
et des américains
il ya une belle coopération et patrick
vous le dira mieux que moi il a des très
bons amis cosmonautes russes
il a des très bons copains astronautes
américains et je ne doute pas qu'ils
connaissent aussi quelques taïkonautes
chinois
ce sont des gens qui se fréquente qui
travaillent ensemble les administrations
travaillent ensemble avec les européens
aussi et globalement c'est pas la guerre
maintenant qui est de la concurrence
c'est certain et j'ai un ami qui les ya
pas longtemps si les américains ne sont
pas sur la lune en 2024
il y aura des restaurants sur le chinois
sur la lune en 2026
c'était assez drôle parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya quand même une vraie
compétition que pour lachine démontré sa
capacité et ses compétences
seule elle a bénéficié de l'aide des
russes pendant longtemps mais seuls
aujourd'hui pour partir à la conquête du
cosmos c'est quelque chose de très
important politiquement
donc oui il ya une complète une
compétition c'est indiscutable est ce
que ces gens pourront travailler
ensemble rassemblés leur budget leur
compte reconnaissance dans certains
domaines c'est sûr dans tous les
domaines certainement pas n'oubliez pas
que aussi l'espace militaire et les
aurès militaire ça ne se partage pas
patrick baudry le mot de la fin sur ce
thème justement emmené par la main et
nous faire des cadeaux donc au niveau et
nous des as pont de bien sûr il ya chez
le manque un problème on s'entend comme
frères et soeurs et on a des procédures
qui sont extrêmement rigoureuses qu'il
faut respecter
donc on a d'autres problèmes gré que les
problèmes politiques mais sur fins
politiques
je ne crois absolument pas que les
américains les russes et des chinois
dans la malle pour conquérir mars quoi
que ce soit déjà la lune va être quelque
chose extrêmement intéressante comme
depuis déjà plusieurs dizaines d'années
là encore puisque on va y trouver des
ressources extrêmement importante et ça
m'étonnerait que les américains invitent
les chinois à partager le gâteau
donc les dix années qui viennent vont
être vraiment très excitante
au-delà de l'aspect purement technique
est échu et autres la conquête spatiale
repart ça va être pour mot la complète
oui nous aussi évidemment merci patrick
baudry et merci michel polacco d'avoir
répondu à nos questions directes sur rtl
à on suivra ça évidemment
samedi avec attention merci à tous les
deux